guns are one of mankind's most ingenious
and deadly inventions
from standard issue handguns to fearsome
beasts like the ones we're about to see
guns have been a wartime staple since
their inception in the 13th century
while most firearms follow a practical
design scheme over the course of the
last several hundred years there have
been some eccentric outliers
in this video we're going to look at
some of the largest most ridiculously
oversized guns in history
let's start with the oldest weapon on
our list the dardanelle's gun
while there were a handful of cannons
technically larger than this one
unlike the dardanelles gun very few of
them were ever fired in anger
the massive cannon was cast out of
bronze way back in 1464 in modern day
turkey
it weighed a staggering 16.8 tons and
was over 5 meters long
the projectiles for this beast were
large stone balls up to 63 centimeters
in diameter
the dardanelle's gun looks impressive
enough on paper but what really makes it
exceptional is that in 1807
340 years after it was built it was
dusted off and pressed back into service
to fend off the british royal navy in
what became known as the dardanelles
operation
the british suffered 28 dead from the
old cannons bombardment
60 years later it was gifted to queen
victoria and it now resides at fort
nelson in hampshire
for those of you who want the absolute
biggest medieval artillery piece and
aren't concerned with its military usage
up for your consideration is the tsar
cannon like the dardanelle's gun this
behemoth was cast in bronze
it was 5.3 meters long and weighed more
than twice the dardanelle's gun a
whopping 39.3 tons
as you might have guessed from its name
the tsar cannon hails from russia
specifically it was crafted in moscow in
1586 by andrei chokov
officially this imposing piece was never
meant to see combat
but was instead designed as a symbol of
russian power and industry
however at least one study of the tsar
cannon has revealed gunpowder residue
which would seem to indicate that it was
fired at least once perhaps
simply a ceremonial puff of smoke
contrary to what its current display
would have you believe
the tsar cannon was only meant to fire
800 kilograms of stone grape shot rather
than solid cannonballs
this earned it the nickname the russian
shotgun to this day
the tsar cannon holds the record for the
largest muzzle loading cannon ever built
moving forward to world war 1 we get a
taste of truly ridiculous scale
between march and august of 1918 the
german empire fielded what became known
as the paris gun
this unprecedented siege weapon had a
barrel length of 34 meters and holds the
prestigious honor of launching the
projectile that became the first
man-made object to enter the
stratosphere
a height not exceeded until the germans
developed their v2 rockets during world
war ii
you heard that right the paris gun was
capable of firing 106 kilogram shells
40 kilometers into the air that's almost
four
times the maximum altitude of today's
commercial airliners
this massive power allowed the paris gun
to bombard targets over 130 kilometers
away
the altitude also had another
complicating effect the flight time per
shell was about three minutes
so long that the germans had to factor
in the rotation of the earth to even hit
the city
when the germans began their barrage of
paris the citizens initially thought
they were under attack from a
high-flying
zeppelin because they could neither hear
an airplane nor a cannon of course
there was a cannon it was just too far
away to here
by the end of its service the paris gun
had fired between 320 and 367 shells and
killed 250 people and wounded an
additional 620 with a significant
portion of the death toll coming from a
single lucky shot on a crowded church
the gun was rushed back to germany as
the allies advanced where it was
dismantled and all schematics presumably
destroyed
jumping forward again to world war ii we
find the germans back at it again with a
new monster weapon
germany thought they would need a way to
break through the french maginot line so
they commissioned an unprecedented
weapon with a shell that could punch
through seven meters of concrete or one
meter of steel armor plating from beyond
the range of the french artillery
an engineer working on the project
calculated that such a feat would
require a weapon with a caliber of 80
centimeters that would weigh over 1 000
tons
supported by not one but two railway
tracks with a projectile weighing seven
tons
as much as a bus so naturally hitler
ordered two of them
the design and construction work got
underway but it soon became apparent
that the guns would not be ready in time
however the german army quickly flanked
the static maginot line through belgium
and its destruction became unnecessary
the first completed gun nicknamed gustav
was eventually deployed at the siege of
sevastopol in the soviet union
where it caused considerable damage with
its massive bust weight shells
the finished gun had a barrel over 30
meters long weighed 1
350 tons and could lob shells nearly 40
kilometers
the massive artillery piece required an
equally massive crew
needing 250 men just to remain in
operation and continue its rate of fire
of one to two shots per hour
besides the men required to operate the
behemoth the gustav gun also called for
1250 engineers
scientists and guards to assemble it
over the course of the four weeks
following its arrival at the front
aboard 25 separate trains it may have
been a marvel of engineering but it was
a logistical nightmare
gustav and its sister gun dora were both
dismantled by the germans near the end
of the war
to this day the gustav railway gun
remains the largest caliber rifled
weapon ever used in combat
the heaviest mobile artillery piece ever
built and fired the heaviest shells of
any artillery piece ever made
and finally the last gun on our list was
never actually finished
but if it had been it would have been
the largest gun ever made
it was called big babylon and was part
of an overarching plan by iraqi
president saddam hussein to create
several super guns
the project was headed by canadian
artillery expert gerald bull
bull had a tumultuous history with many
world powers spearheading the
development of advanced artillery
capable of launching satellites into
space
but also dabbling in illegal arms
dealing after a short stint in prison he
built a personal rapport with hussein
and convinced him that iraq needed such
advanced capabilities if it were ever to
become a regional power
construction began on what was called
baby babylon a smaller scale prototype
of the planned super gun
despite its reduced capabilities baby
babylon would have had a range of almost
650 kilometers
the real goal big babylon was planned to
be over 156 meters long
weigh 2 100 tons and have a bore of one
meter
this absurdly huge artillery piece would
have had the capability to fire two-ton
projectiles into orbit
where they could be guided to strike
anywhere on the planet when iraq invaded
kuwait in 1990
bull suddenly found himself working for
a man considered the enemy of almost
every nation on earth
in march of the same year bull was
assassinated with five shots to the back
of the neck as he entered his apartment
in brussels
there's much speculation regarding who
had bull assassinated
but the mystery has never been solved
regardless of the culprit
project babylon died with bull had it
been completed
big babylon would have been the most
ridiculously huge weapon ever devised
and it's doubtful if any such project
will ever be attempted again
if you'd like to learn more about the
history of super guns and other
artillery check out the links in the
description
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe to keep up to date with the
latest content
you can watch my previous video by
clicking here or watch my other videos
about weapons by clicking here
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next video